wir sind beim nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt es geht um zwei
Anträge und ein Gesetzentwurf der
afd-fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag alle
drei Vorlagen beschäftigen sich mit
kovit 19 Maßnahmen beispielsweise will
die afd-fraktion das Impfungen bei
Minderjährigen AFD 19 Impfung
wohlgemerkt ausgesetzt werden sie möchte
eine Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes nämlich das
Masken nur noch freiwillig getragen
werden müssen und sie fordert in einem
Antrag die Bundesregierung auf eine
Rechtsordnung
Rechtsverordnung zu erlassen die die
maskenpflicht aussetzt also alles drei
rund um das Thema 19 teilweise ist das
in einzelnen Bundesländern schon erfolgt
was die maskenpflichte beispielsweise im
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr angeht
aber die afd-fraktion möchte es
genereller und wie Aussprache wird in
diesem Moment eröffnet erste Rednerin
ist Christina Baum sie ist Mitglied im
Gesundheit Ausschuss
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
in wenigen Tagen werden wir wieder
Weihnachten feiern das Fest dass sie den
Menschen in den vergangenen Jahr zwei
Jahren am liebsten verboten hätten das
fest dass viele ein letztes Mal erlebten
in Einsamkeit und danach um danach
einsam zu sterben und einsam beerdigt zu
werden dieses Bild steht stellvertretend
für das ganze Leid dass sie den Menschen
in diesen zwei Jahren angetan haben
die von ihnen beschlossenen
Zwangsmaßnahmen haben so unglaublich
viel Tränen und Schmerz über unser Land
gebracht dass diese Zeit niemand
vergessen wird Kinder wurden unter
Masken gezwungen und von ihren
Schulkameraden getrennt in eine Ecke
gesetzt sie mussten am offenen Fenster
frieren nur weil sie aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen keine Maske
tragen konnten und der Schmerzen wurden
ihnen die Teststäbchen in die Nase
geschoben und jedes Mal schlug ihr Puls
schneller aus Angst vor einem positiven
Ergebnis mit anschließender Isolation
eine Mutter schrieb allen Abgeordneten
dass ihre Tochter morgens gar nicht mehr
aufwachen wolle weil die Schule die
Hölle sei so wie es meine Kollegen im
Landtag kalt gelassen hat hat auch sie
im Bundestag das Leid der Menschen nicht
erreicht und so wie sie bei diesen
Maßnahmen falsch schlagen legen Sie auch
mit ihrer impfverherrlichung falsch aus
dem verniedlichen den kleinen Peaks der
einen jahrelangen vollen Schutz ohne
Nebenwirkungen garantieren sollte wurde
ein in eine Injektion die weder den
fremd noch den Eigenschutz noch einen
Schutz vor einem schweren Verlauf
garantiert
dafür aber schwerwiegende Nebenwirkungen
bis hin zum Tod mit sich bringen kann
ich zitiere dr Beate Jäger Internistin
aus einem zdf-bericht vom
4.12.2022 ich habe hier Kinder behandelt
die konnten nicht mehr den Kopf heben
sie konnte nicht sprechen ich habe
gestern die Mutter eines Mädchens
gesehen dass seit acht Monaten die Decke
anstatt und gefüttert werden muss die
vorher völlig gesund war Zitat ändern
das sind nur wenige Fälle von
zigtausenden die völlig unnötig geimpft
worden weil für sie Corona niemals ein
Risiko dargestellt hätte
alle hier von ganz links bis zur CDU
sind dafür verantwortlich für das was
geschehen ist und auch für das was immer
noch geschieht um weiteren Schaden
abzuwenden bitte ich Sie deshalb
eindringlich entschädigen und
rehabilitieren sie die Opfer und
schützen Sie unsere Kinder indem Sie
dieses gefährliche impf-experiment
endgültig beenden und hören Sie auch mit
diesem Masken Wahnsinn auf ich zitiere
Florian Hoffmann Oberarzt auf einer
Kinderintensivstation in München in
vielen deutschen Kinderkliniken
herrschen derzeit Zustände welche in die
Dritte Welt erinnern die Stationen sind
brechend voll und Eltern mit
schwerkranken Kindern müssen teilweise
auf Pritschen in der Notaufnahme
nächtigen Zitat Ende verantwortlich für
das gehäufte Auftreten von schweren RSV
Fällen sind laut Hoffmann und anderen
Medizinern maskenzwang kita-schließungen
und kontaktverbote
jeder einzelne von ihnen sollte sich
wirklich sehr genau überlegen ob er
weitere Schuld auf sich leiden möchte
stimmen Sie unseren Anträgen zu das wäre
ein Anfang vielen Dank
[Applaus]
die Sicht von Christina Baum auf die
aktuelle kurierten 19 Lage insbesondere
im Hinblick auf
kranke Kinder die nächste Rednerin in
dieser Debatte ist Lisa hat über radari
aus der
spd-fraktionsärztin von Beruf auch
Christina Baum die eben gesprochen hat
diese Zahnärztin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
täglich grüßt das Murmeltier wieder
einmal dürfen wir uns heute mit einem
Antrag der AFD beschäftigen der
jeglicher Grundlage entbehrt und allein
das Ziel hat die Bevölkerung zu
verunsichern und ihre Gesundheit zu
schädigen
man kann das inzwischen nicht mehr als
verantwortungslos bezeichnet sondern nur
noch als bewusst destruktiv heute auf
dem Menü ist ein Raunen der Antrag für
Sie mit ein paar Fußnoten von
überwiegend etablierten Organisationen
die dem Ganzen einen anscheinend vom
Wissenschaftlichkeit verleihen sollen
zwar bringen sie teils die richtigen
Stellen an aber verkehren deren Inhalt
für ihre eingeschritten eingeschränkte
Sicht der Dinge vollkommen nun wollen
sie also die Kinder die Impfung von
Kindern aussetzen
mal ganz abgesehen davon dass jetzt in
ihrer Fraktion gänzlich an der
Medizinischen Expertise mangelt um
solche Forderungen aufzustellen zu
können zu können mangelt es ihnen
offensichtlich obendrein auch noch an
der politischen es gibt in Deutschland
auf guten Gründen eine ständige
Impfkommission STIKO genannt die damit
befasst ist zu beschließen welche
Impfungen in Deutschland für welche
Altersgruppe empfohlen werden es ist
nicht die Aufgabe dieses Hauses an der
STIKO vorbei solche Entscheidungen zu
treffen oder auch sie nur zu bewerten
es geht ihnen nicht um die Kinder
ging es ihnen um die Kinder hätten sie
sich einmal ernsthaft mit den
Ergebnissen der Studien zu kurvitimpfung
bei Kinder und Jugendlichen beschäftigt
erst einmal ja das Risiko bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen schwer an Kurve zu
erkranken ist im Vergleich zu
Erwachsenen deutlich geringer das
bestreitet niemand ernsthaft
die krankheitsbelastung nahmen mit den
verschiedenen Varianten des Coronavirus
ab aber es gibt Kinder mit Behinderung
und chronischen Erkrankung die daran
weiterhin ernsthaft erkranken können
laut Markus Hufnagel pädiatrische
infektiologe im Zentrum für Kinder und
Jugendmedizin des Universitätsklinikums
Freiburg wird jetzt aufpassen Mitte
durch die Lockerungen der Maßnahmen mit
mehr betroffenen Kindern mit meist
diffusen und länger anhaltenden
gesundheitlichen Problemen sogar
gerechnet
Studien in Schild und hospitals in Texas
und Philadelphia zeigen und zeigen dass
es durch das sogenannte
postinflamatorische Syndrom bei Kindern
schwere Entzündungen an Gefäßen und
Geweben gibt die mit
herz-kreislaufkollaps und
mikrothrombosen mit tödlichem Ausgang
deutsche Mediziner nehmen die mögliche
Gefahr von kovit 19 Langzeitfolgen für
Kinder und Jugendliche ebenfalls sehr
ernst für die Studie Augsburg plus am
Klinikum Augsburg sollen ca 500 Kinder
Mädchen und Jungen aus Kindergärten
Schulen und weiterführende Schulen
mehrfach getestet und begleitet werden
all das sind Fakten die es ernst zu
nehmen gibt
deswegen hat die STIKO es sich auch
nicht leicht gemacht und sehr vorsichtig
agiert denn erst wurde die Impfung nur
Jugendlichen zwischen 12 und 17 Jahren
mit Vorerkrankungen empfohlen bei einer
Rate von postaktionale New yorkatitis
also Herzmuskelentzündung mit einer
Häufigkeit von maximal 69 Fällen auf
eine Million Impfdosen bei männlichen
Jugendlichen und maximal zehn Fällen bei
weiblichen Jugendlichen erfolgte erst im
August 2021 die allgemeine Empfehlung
für diese Altersgruppe seit Januar 2022
wird auch eine Auffrischimpfung
empfohlen die wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnisse sind nicht in Stein
gemeißelt die Kommission evaluiert ihre
eigene Impfempfehlung ständig und
reagiert auf neue Studien und
Entwicklung darauf vertrauen die
Menschen in Deutschland
und darauf können auch Sie vertrauen
trauen haben wir im Parlament nicht zu
untergraben auch wenn wir uns vielleicht
manchmal gewünscht hätten dass diese
schwierige Arbeit schneller vonstatten
geht aber Gründlichkeit kommt vor
Schnelligkeit
am meisten am meisten Sorgen macht mir
aber der Gedanke daran was ihre
pseudawissenschaftlichen Anträge und
Veröffentlichung draußen in der realen
Welt anrichten können schon jetzt
schon jetzt hat die Pandemie bei
verschiedenen Impfungen dazu geführt
dass die Impfquote bei den jüngsten
zurückgegangen sind der DRK Kinder und
jugendreport 2022 zeigt sinkende
Impfquoten vor allem bei der
gesamtimpfung und Auffrischimpfung gegen
Diphtherie Tetanus Keuchhusten und
Kinderlähmung aber auch bei der Impfung
gegen HPV
weltweit zweiten Impfung gegen Krebs
speziell gegen Gebärmutterhalskrebs und
Peniskrebs sind die Zahlen
zurückgegangen und alarmierend ihr
ursachliches und unwissenschaftliches
Vorgehen gegen die Kurve Impfung während
alte ressortiments gegen Impfung im
Allgemeinen auch zu einem Zeitpunkt als
wir bei vielen Krankheiten schon nah an
der Ausrottung waren
in ihre Angst vor Bedeutungsverlust in
der corona-pandemie haben sie dieses
Gift in weite Teile der Gesellschaft
getragen da können Sie noch so viele
Anträge stellen und aktuelle Stunden
andauern wir werden Ihnen weiterhin
lautstark und immer wieder oft neueste
wissenschaftlich fundiert und sachlich
widersprechen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit sagt die Kinder und
jugendärztin in Mesa hat barandari aus
der SPD-Fraktion in dieser Debatte des
Bundestages wo es zum Maßnahmen gegen
kobit 19 geht die AFD gerne aufgehoben
hätte beispielsweise was Impfungen von
Minderjährigen angeht der nächste Redner
ist Georg kippels und der kommt aus der
Unionsfraktion
Unwahrheiten werden nicht durch
ständiges Wiederholen zu Tatsachen das
haben wir gerade eben sehr eindrücklich
erlebt
mit Hartnäckigkeit
Ignoranz Desinformationen Verkürzungen
von Zitaten werden
Ängste geschürt Befürchtungen
hervorgerufen und sie dienen dem
einzigen Zweck die Bevölkerung gegen den
Staat und seine Institutionen
aufzubringen
widmen wir uns aber aus besonderem
Anlass jetzt zur Weihnachtszeit stehen
die Kinder immer bei uns im besonderen
Interesse und wir widmen Ihnen viel
Zuwendungen und vor allen Dingen die
Sorgen um ihre Gesundheit und deshalb
wenn an diesem Nachmittag oder an diese
Mittag diese Debatte nur irgendeinen
vernünftigen Sinn haben soll kann man
sie dazu nutzen den Eltern die Hinweise
geben wo sie sich sachlich über die
Fragestellung der Impfung ihrer Kinder
informieren können
am gästigen Tag hat die schnieke eine
wiederum überarbeitete Impfempfehlung
veröffentlicht vom 15.12 die letzte vom
7.12 also man ist doch hart am Geschehen
und bemüht sich alle Veränderungen
Entwicklungen Erkenntnisse einfließen zu
lassen die wesentliche Unterscheidung
bei der Impfempfehlung sind vier
Altersgruppen zunächst von sechs Monaten
bis vier Jahren Kindesalter 5 bis 11
Jahren und dann über 12 bis zur
Volljährigkeit des Weiteren ist ein
wesentliches
Unterscheidungskriterium für die
Impfentscheidung ob es gesunde Kinder
sind Kinder mit Vorerkrankungen diese
sind im Einzelnen in dieser
Impfempfehlung mit 11 Unterpunkten
erwähnt und beschrieben dann gibt es die
Gruppe der Kinder mit Kontakten zu
Risikopersonen und es geht natürlich
auch entscheidend um die Frage der
jeweiligen Auffrischungen vor allen
Dingen bei bereits durchlebter
Infektionen ebenso genau
angewiesen und unterschieden wird die
Frage der Dosis und insbesondere die
Anwendung des speziellen Kinderimpfstoff
dieser ganze Prozess wird von Anfang an
verantwortungsvoll durch RKI und pay
begleitet und es gibt eine
ununterbrochene Anpassung dieser für die
Eltern wichtigen Informationen und
letztlich kann immer nur empfohlen
werden dass das Gespräch mit dem Arzt
dem Kinderarzt des Vertrauens gesucht
wird um die in die Welt individuellen
Bedürfnisse der Kinder zu erfahren
das ist wissenschaftlich belegt
das ist internationaler Konsens und das
ist vor allen Dingen in der jetzigen
Zeit bei der Überlagerung durch RSV und
weitere Infektionserkrankungen die sich
verschoben haben außerordentlich wichtig
um die richtige Entscheidung und vor
allen Dingen auch die richtige
Begleitung für die Eltern zu finden wir
alle hier
seit über zwei Jahren mit den wichtigen
Maßnahmen aber es ist gerade auch zu
Recht gesagt und die STIKO ist eine
unabhängige Gruppe eine unabhängige
Institution und der schenken mir
vertrauen weil wir wissen dass dort
Fachkunde mit dem notwendigen Interesse
am Schutz unserer Kinder gegeneinander
abgewogen wird
wir brauchen
grundsätzlich aber insbesondere hier und
heute keine Verunsicherung wir brauchen
keinen verantwortungslosen Unsinn und
wir brauchen keine Desinformation wir
brauchen im Grunde genommen das was
tagtäglich hier aus dem Hause und aus
dem Hause der RKI geschieht die
Bemühungen um das Wohlbefinden unserer
Kinder und das ist mit einer
verantwortungsvollen Impfung zu leisten
deshalb diese Botschaft vom heutigen
Tage ist wahrscheinlich das einzig
nützliche als Reaktion auf diesen
vollkommen verfährten Antrag ich wünsche
allen eine vor Adventszeit und bleiben
Sie bitte gesund vielen Dank
georg kippels war das aus der
Unionsfraktion der Bundestag diskutiert
zwei Anträge und ein Gesetzentwurf der
afd-fraktion zu corona-maßnahmen bzw zu
nicht corona-maßnahmen der nächste
Redner ist Armin grau aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 gegründet Mitglied im
Gesundheitsausschuss Liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von den
demokratischen Parteien es ist
ungeheuerlich wie hier in diesem Haus
zum wiederholten Male von der AFD die
corona-pandemie komplett umgedeutet wird
nicht die Pandemie nicht das Virus sei
das gefährliche sondern die Maßnahmen
dagegen das ist eine unsägliche
Verkehrung der Wahrheit sie verkaufen
die Menschen hier im Haus und draußen
die uns zuhören allesamt für dumm
wir haben es hier wieder einmal mit
Anträgen der AFD zu tun die zumindest in
der Begründung deutlich machen dass
diese Partei nicht an einem seriösen und
faktenbasierten Dialog interessiert ist
noch immer sterben jeden Tag über fast
jeden Tag deutlich über 100 Menschen im
Zusammenhang mit Covic 19 auch
minderjährige können schwer an der
Krankheit erkranken und auch daran
versterben und selbst Menschen und
Kinder die zum Glück von einem schweren
Verlauf verschont geblieben sind laufen
Gefahr später an longkowitz zu leiden
Corona ist und bleibt gegen ihre
Einschätzung von der AFD eine wirklich
gefährliche Erkrankung und sicherlich
gilt es ständig zu evaluieren welche
Maßnahmen zu welchem Zeitpunkt
verhältnismäßig sind und notwendig sind
so Eindämmung der Pandemie hier muss man
auch inhaltlich nicht immer derselben
Meinung sein aber dieser Diskurs muss
sachlich geführt werden sie wurden dass
die maskenpflicht negative Auswirkung
auf die Volksgesundheit habe und streuen
gegen alle wissenschaftliche Evidenz
Zweifel am Wert der Masken
deren Wert ist aber in großen Studien
eindeutig und ohne Zweifel belegt es
gibt erhebliche Schutzwirkung durch
Masken da gibt es wissenschaftliche
Einheitlichkeit und das kann man zwar
sagen das wäre sich selber schützen will
der kann das ja tun aber auch da gibt es
ganz klare Zusammenhänge wenn ich mich
selber mit einer Maske Schütze ist das
gut aber wenn man gegenüber zusätzlich
eine Maske trägt ist das für die
Übertragung des Virus natürlich noch
viel besseres verstärkt die
Schutzwirkung die gerade für vulnerable
Gruppen so wichtig ist
und es ist auf langen Zugreisen sehr
entscheidend wo man ohne großen Abstand
zusammensetzt Solidarität ist eben der
Kit der diese Gesellschaft zusammenhält
das ist etwas was sie von der AFD nie
verstanden haben wir sitzen eben alle im
selben Boot und hier besser im Zug ich
weiß nicht ob sie gestern in der Debatte
mitbekommen haben wir sind die
Versorgung der Kinder bei uns steht
jetzt ist es so wichtig dass ich zu den
RS und Influenza Viruserkrankung nicht
auch noch eine erhöhte Zahlen Corona
Erkrankung dazu gesellt wir müssen
unsere Kinder und andere vulnerable
Gruppenverwaltung Ansteckungen dringend
schützen da ist es klug dass wir jetzt
über den Winter die Schutzmaßnahmen zum
Beispiel die maskenpflicht im
Fernverkehr beibehalten natürlich werden
wir das pandemiegeschehen weiter genauso
ins beobachten und evaluieren wann auf
welche Maßnahmen dann verzichtet werden
kann oder eben auch nicht grundlage
dafür ist aber eine auf
wissenschaftliche
evidenzbasierende Debatte die sich
anders als die Falschbehauptung und die
Hetze der AFD um Ernsthaftigkeit und
Gewissenhaftigkeit bemüht ich wünsche
Ihnen allen schöne Weihnachten und dann
auch einen guten Start im neuen Jahr
sobald Armin grau von den Bündnisgrünen
über das Thema Kubik 19 Impfungen
atemschutzmaskenpflicht des Volk jetzt
als nächste Rednerin Vogler von der
Linken
gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin ihrer
Fraktion Kolleginnen
die allgemeine fake-partei Deutschlands
kurz AFD verlangt heute allen Ernstes
dass der Bundestag per Beschluss die
Impfung von Minderjährigen gegen das
saskow zwei Virus aussetzen soll ich
will Ihnen mal was erklären in
Deutschland ist es zum Glück nicht so
dass Juristen und Kaufleute von denen es
speziell in ihrer Fraktion viel zu viele
gibt für meinen Geschmack nach
politischen Vorstellungen darüber
entscheiden welche Impfungen für welche
Personengruppen empfohlen werden sondern
das tun bei uns Medizinerinnen und
Mediziner auf der
basiswissenschaftlicher Erkenntnisse und
die Linke streitet dafür dass das so
bleibt und natürlich berufen sie sich
bei ihren Forderungen auch immer wieder
auf Studien aber jedes Mal wenn man
genauer hinschaut stellt man fest da ist
irgendwas schräg also ich zitiere jetzt
mal den Kardiologen dr Daniel Messi da
können Sie ruhig zuhören Herr Baumann
vom Deutschen Herzzentrum der genau an
dieser Studie mitwirkt deren Ergebnisse
sie abwarten wollen bevor Kinder und
Jugendliche wieder Zugang zu Impfstoffen
bekommen dürfen nach ihrer Auffassung er
sagt mit unserer Kooperation mit dem
paul Ehrlich Institut wollen wir einen
Beitrag zur umfassenden Erforschung der
Nebenwirkungen von mRNA Impfstoffen
gegen eine corona-infektion leisten aber
damit keinesfalls den Nutzen dieser
Impfungen in Frage stellen denn es darf
längst als absolut gesichert gelten dass
die mit einer Corvette 19 Erkrankung
verbundenen Gefahren bei weitem die
Risiken einer Impfung überwiegen auch
bei Kindern über zwölf Jahren und bei
Jugendlichen und
für die nicht ganz so schnellen Denkerin
wiederhole ich das noch mal die mit
einer corvit 19 Erkrankung verbundenen
Gefahren überwiegen bei weitem die
Risiken einer Impfung auch bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen ab 12 Jahren so und
ausger die AFD die sonst immer den
Eltern Willen betont und sich gegen
staatliche Einmischung in die Familien
verwahrt will Eltern nun ein Instrument
aus der Hand nehmen zum Schutz ihrer
Kinder rein aus politischem Kalkül und
nicht aus Sorge und mir das Kindeswohl
spüren Sie sich eigentlich noch und dann
nochmal zum Thema Masken also ich wäre
ja sehr für eine sofortige Aufhebung der
maskenpflicht in Verkehrsmitteln wenn
das sinnvoll wäre aber ich weiß nicht ob
sie es mitbekommen haben dass gerade
eine wahre Infektionswelle durch das
Land läuft und es sind vielen Apotheken
nicht einmal mehr fiebersenker oder
Hustensäfte gibt und betroffen sind
diesmal ganz besonders die Kinder die in
der corona-pandemie alle
Präventionsmaßnahmen mitmachen mussten
um uns Erwachsene zu schützen also ich
finde es nur fair wenn wir das jetzt mal
andersrum machen
die Kinder Kinder und ihre Familien
waren in den letzten drei Jahren die
größten Verlierer der Krise die Politik
hat es versäumt die Schulen und Kitas zu
sicheren Orten zu machen die sie
eigentlich sein dort mit Luftfiltern
kleineren Lerngruppen und allem was
nötig wäre da ist viel wieder gut zu
machen aber ihre Anträge leisten dazu
gar keinen sinnvollen Beitrag
das Wort erhält Christine Aschenberg
dugnos für die FDP-Fraktion Christine
der gesundheitspolitischen Sprecherin
der Linken Fraktion ist die Aschenberg
ist Parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
in ihrer Fraktion
Impfung bei Minderjährigen aussätzen
versuche ich es jetzt mal im Gegensatz
zur antragstellenden Fraktion mit
belegbaren Fakten
seit gut zwei Jahren steht uns der
corona-impfstoff in Deutschland zur
Verfügung und diesen Blick nach hinten
müssen wir uns noch mal gestatten am
Anfang hatten wir zu wenig Impfstoffe
und es musste eine Priorisierung
vorgenommen werden die Ständige
Impfkommission beim Robert-Koch-Institut
der Deutsche Ethikrat und die
Nationalakademie der Wissenschaft
Leopoldina haben seinerzeit ein
Positionspapier für eine solche
Priorisierung vorgelegt darauf aufbauend
wurde dann eine impfstrategie entwickelt
die eben eine Priorisierung für
bestimmte Gruppen an menschenwulderablen
Gruppen vorsagt inzwischen haben wir
Gott sei Dank und da können wir doch
sehr froh darüber sein keine
impfstoffknappheit mehr in Deutschland
ganz im Gegenteil jeder Mann jede Frau
jedes Kind kann sich beim Arzt oder der
Ärztin seines Vertrauens eine Impfung
mit unterschiedlichen Impfstoffen
abholen und das ist doch etwas worüber
wir froh sein müssen meine Damen und
Herren
und was mir ganz besonders in diesem
Zusammenhang wichtig ist wie als
fdp-bundestagsfraktionen haben auch zur
Oppositionszeiten immer auf die
Einschätzung der Ständigen
Impfkommission Bezug genommen denn die
unabhängige stimmige Impfkommission
orientiert sich an den Kriterien der
evidenzbasierten Medizin meine Damen und
Herren etwas was in diesem Antrag leider
überhaupt nicht vorkommt
sie ist es auch die aus diesen
evidenzbasierten Erkenntnissen
Impfempfehlungen entwickelt
Impfempfehlungen und diese
Impfempfehlung gab es lange Zeit nicht
für die minderjährige Bevölkerung aber
im November 2021 wurde dann endlich der
corona-impfstoff für die fünf bis
Elfjährigen in Europa zugelassen und ein
Jahr später im November 22 also diesen
Jahres wurde nun auch von der STIKO eine
Impfempfehlung für kleinere Kinder ab
einem Alter von sechs Monaten
ausgesprochen das war und ist eine
wunderbare Nachricht für alle Familien
mit Kindern hier in Deutschland meine
Damen und Herren und dafür darauf sind
wir auch stolz
für die Gruppe der fünf bis elfjährigen
empfiehlt die Deko zunächst eine
corona-schutzimpfung mit einem
mrna-impfstoff um eine gute
basisimmunität aufzubauen bei Kindern
mit bestimmten Vorerkrankungen oder auch
einem immunefizit empfiehlt die Deko 2
Impfungen sowie zwei
Auffrischungsimpfungen Kinder ohne
Vorerkrankungen die aber Kontakt zu war
gründerablen Gruppen haben sollten
ebenfalls zwei Impfungen für eine
Grundimmunisierung erhalten für kleinere
vorerkrankte Kinder ab sechs Monaten bis
vier Jahren empfiehlt die STIKO eine
Grundimmunisierung mit drei Impfdosen
warum erzähle ich Ihnen das meine Damen
und Herren das ist eine differenzierte
Impfempfehlung an denen sich die Eltern
orientieren können gemeinsam mit ihrem
Kinderarzt oder Kinderärztin und er
brauchen wir solche schwachsinnigen
Anträge nicht denn die Eltern wissen
sehr gut
wie es um die Gesundheit ihrer Kinder
steht und wo Sie diese Empfehlung
abholen können
das sind die Fakten und jetzt kommen sie
mit so einem Antrag wo sie eine
impfmöglichkeit aussetzen wollen das ist
doch unglaublich meine Damen und Herren
diese Entscheidung treffen Eltern mit
ihren Kindern und nicht mit ihren
Kindern aber für ihre Kinder gemeinsam
so ist es richtig so habe ich es auch
immer mit unserer Tochter gemacht die
gegen alles geimpft ist was es gab zum
Beispiel auch gegen HPV-Impfung so ist
es der richtige Weg ich persönlich habe
es auch so gemacht ich bin doppelt
geimpft ich bin doppelt gebustert das
war meine Entscheidung und dazu braucht
es nur einen guten Arzt der ein äh
darüber eben auch aufklärt meine Damen
und Herren wir wollen die diese
Entscheidung den Sorgeberechtigten
überlassen und nicht der Politik und äh
deswegen ist dieser Antrag auch naja ich
will jetzt mal höflich sein nicht
weiterführend meine Damen und Herren er
trägt zumindest in keiner Weise den
wissenschaftlichen erkennt diesen
Rechnungen ich bin froh dass die
Wissenschaft im Stoffe auf den Markt
gebracht gesagt hat die allen Menschen
zur Verfügung stehen ich bin froh dass
die impfentscheidungen für Kinder von
den Eltern getroffen werden und von
niemandem anderen und ich bin froh dass
die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung sich nicht
von abwegigen Fake News orientieren und
irritieren lässt meine Damen und Herren
meine Hoffnung
dass ich evidenzbasierte Erkenntnisse
unter anderem von der Ständigen
Impfkommission auch bei ihnen
durchsetzen geht leider in Null aber es
ist Weihnachten und die Hoffnung stirbt
ja bekanntlich zuletzt vielleicht bringt
das Christkind ja auch bei ihnen mal
etwas Erleuchtung vielen Dank
soweit Christine aschenberg-dognos mit
dem Hinweis dass hier die COBIT
Impfungen bei Minderjährigen eine
Empfehlung ist das der der stigo der
ständig innenkonfusion die man ja
schlecht aussetzen kann jetzt vielleicht
eine gegenteilige Erläuterung von Fabian
Jacobi von der AFD
so
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der maskenzwang wackelt und Feld Bayern
und Sachsen-Anhalt sind vorangegangen
Schleswig-Holstein folgt gut so
Fernzüge hat der Gesetzgeber den
maskenzwang ins Gesetz geschrieben Jan
Kündigung des Ministers Buschmann alle
Maßnahmen endeten im April 22 war
wertlos der Bundestag hat mit den
Stimmen der FDP die maskenregelung
verlängert das war falsch die
Fortsetzung des maskenzwangs in Zügen
trotz abschaffungen Flugzeugen legt die
Willkür der Maßnahmen offen der
Sachverständigenausschuss kam im Juli
schon zu dem Ergebnis dass ein Nutzen
der Maskerade unter Realbedingungen
nicht belegt sein damit ist Ihre
Fortführung nicht zurechtfertigen zum
Glück gibt es einen Ausweg die
Bundesregierung kann die maskenpflicht
entfernen Zügen sofort aussetzen ohne
erst das Gesetz zu ändern Herr Lindner
hat getwittert er hoffe dass der
bayerische Entschluss bundesweit Schule
macht bitteschön Herr Lindner hier ist
Ihre Chance nach der Ankündigung ihres
Vorsitzenden erwarte ich die Zustimmung
der FDP-Fraktion zu unserem Antrag
vielen Dank
Fabian Jacobi von der AFD mit der
Erläuterung die maskenpflicht in
Fernverkehrszügen auszusetzen das war
ein Redebeitrag von einer Minute auch
das gibt es im Bundestag das ist keine
Willkür sondern das ist abgemacht im
ältesten radier nach der Stärke der
Fraktion nächster Redner er darf fünf
Minuten reden Herbert Wollmann von der
spd-gesundheitsausschuss ist er Mitglied
und er ist von Beruf Allgemeinarzt ich
frage mich erneut an einem Freitag
nachmittag wie oft sollen wir uns noch
mit den Querdenken den Anträgen der AFD
hier herumschlagen
und immer wieder das gleiche mit
pseudo-wissenschaftlichen Zitaten
unklarer Quellen das muss man so sagen
werden seitens der AFD Unwahrheiten in
die Welt gesetzt nur um die Bevölkerung
zu verunsichern und sich hier in Szene
zu setzen denken Sie an die Anhörungen
denken Sie an die Anhörungen in Bezug
auf Corona immer wieder wird dieser
ominöse heraußen seitens der AFD für
abstruse Stellungnahmen herangezogen ein
Mann der aus der kassierende stammt er
nennt sich datenanalyst ich sage bewusst
er ist ein datenfälscher
auch keine medizinischen Kongress
dürften solche pseudo-sachverständigen
mehr als einmal ihre Show abziehen
es ist in den Ausschüssen zwar üblich
Anhörungen grundsätzlich zuzustimmen
aber ich denke es wird Zeit von dieser
Vorgehensweise irgendwann mal abzurücken
es kann nicht sein dass wir als
Gesundheitspolitiker ständig so viel
Zeit mit überflüssigen Anhörung und
Anträgen der AFD verbringen
das habe ich nicht gesagt ich habe nur
gesagt dass wir querdenkenden Leuten
hier nicht unbedingt
Plattform bieten müssen von Anfang an
hat ihr AFD die kurve-impfungen
verteufelt und die corona-maßnahmen
abgelehnt dabei zeichnet sich immer mehr
ab dass Deutschland die corona-pandemie
besser bewältigt hat als fast alle
anderen Länder auf dieser Welt aber das
will die AFD nicht wahrhaben dass die
großen impferfolge dass die großen
interfolge in der allgemeinen
Bevölkerung aber auch in einigen
Fachkreisen leider oft in Frage gestellt
werden ist im Prinzip nichts neues das
hat vor drei 400 Jahren mit der
Pockenimpfung angefangen ging weiter mit
der Diphtherie und hat die Masern
erreicht und mittlerweile leider auch
die Querdenker der Gegenwart
immer gab es gab es Gegnerschaft immer
setze sich am Ende der Nutzen der
Impfungen durch immer wie kommt diese in
einigen Kreisen verbreitete Ablehnung
Zustande auf der einen Seite liegt es
daran dass gerade wegen des impferfolgs
viele Erkrankungen den Menschen
unbekannt geworden sind und deshalb die
Notwendigkeit eines Impfschutzes leider
nicht mehr eingesehen wird bei der AFD
hat die Ablehnung aber
ganz andere Gründe oder weiterreichende
Gründe man kennt zwar die Erkrankung
kurvit 19 aber man will die
Ernsthaftigkeit der Kurve 19 Erkrankung
seitens der AFD einfach nicht anerkennen
wenn ihr grundlegenden Fehleinschätzung
auf die Schwere der covid-erkrankung
stellt die AFD sämtliche Maßnahmen in
Bezug auf corona-strategien in Frage
und da die Impfung in der Überwindung
der corona-pandemie eine ganz
entscheidende Rolle gespielt hat und
noch spielt werden von der AFD
logischerweise auch die Impfungen als
unnütz angesehen das könnte man ja noch
hinnehmen aber das perfide am Vorgehen
der AFD ist die immer wiederkehrende
Behauptung
die Impfungen sei nicht nur lustlos
sondern auch schädlich und das wird
behauptet ohne irgendwelche Tatsachen
beizubringen
gehen wir doch nur mal von den Hohen
Haus hier aus es ist sehr wahrscheinlich
dass von uns 80%
mehrfach geimpft sind würden die
Behauptung der AFD in Bezug auf die
Gefährlichkeit der Impfung stimmen so
wären wir andauernd Beschluss und fähig
was den Vorteil hätte dass wir
verbliebenen schon auf dem Weg in den
Weihnachtsurlaub wären
nun schlägt die AFD ein neues Kapitel
auf und versucht sich in Kinder und
Jugendmedizin zu profilieren auch das
ist zum Scheitern verurteilt weil es wie
immer unsachlich ist
meine Kollegin Frau Barbara darin ist
Kinderärztin und hat viel kompetenter
als ich die Sachlage der Kinder und
Jugendmedizin dargelegt und auch sehr
viele
kompetenter als sie Frau Kollegin oder
Dr
Baum
es gibt derzeit keinen einzigen Grund
von den Empfehlungen der Ständigen
Impfkommission abzuweichen ich warne
dringend
vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten ich
warme dringend davor dass vom Bundestag
direkt auf die Ständige Impfkommission
eingewirkt wird
statt Impfungen zu verteufeln müssen wir
alles daran setzen der zunehmenden
Impfmüdigkeit entgegenzuwirken die
Anträge der AFD schaden der Gesundheit
sie sind daher abzulehnen danke
soweit Herbert Bollmann von der SPD der
die
Gesetzesinitiativen und die Anträge der
AFD hier in Zweifel zieht und sie
ablehnt Emil zeulner von der CDU
csu-bundestagsfraktion ist die nächste
Rednerin
Bezug auf die Impfungen ein unabhängiges
Expertengremium bräuchten die das so
richtig gut bewerten könnten und jetzt
würde ich mir sagen ja dieses
unabhängige Expertengremium wer sollte
da dann eigentlich drin sitzen also zum
Beispiel natürlich am besten medizinisch
vorgebildet jemand mit jahrelanger
Praxiserfahrung am besten noch aktiv im
Beruf stehend also immer wieder aktuell
mit der Praxis auch zu tun haben jemand
und Leute die in standing haben in der
Gesellschaft aber auch natürlich in der
Wissenschaft unter den Kollegen die
unabhängig sind am besten die auch
ehrenamtlich tätig sind also die nicht
bezahlt werden für das was sie tun die
keine finanziellen Interessen haben
diese auf jeden Fall offenlegen müssen
die renommiert sind selbstbewusst genug
sind eben auch Parteien und Ministern
gegen Widerrede zu halten und jetzt
kommt die Überraschung dieses Gremium
das haben wir in unserem Land das nennt
sich Ständige Impfkommission und
deshalb gilt es heute auch in der
letzten Sitzung des Deutschen Bundestag
wirklich ein herzlichen Dank zu sagen
denn dort sitzen Menschen drin die jetzt
über Jahre wirklich auch schwere
Debatten geführt haben die
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so richtig in
die Öffentlichkeit wollten sondern die
das gemacht haben aus einer inneren
Motivation heraus weil sie gewusst haben
es braucht eben mehr als eben einen
Einsatz von vielleicht 8 Uhr bis um 16
Uhr sondern ich muss danach noch
arbeiten für die Gesellschaft für die
Gemeinschaft und ich bin auch bereit
mich öffentlich zu Dingen zu bekennen
und eben in die Auseinandersetzung zu
gehen und deshalb muss wirklich der
große Dank an die Verantwortlichen an
die ehrenamtlich Tätigen in der
Ständigen Impfkommission auch gehen und
eine Entscheidung ob ein
ob ein Kind
geimpft werden soll oder nicht das
sollte in die Verantwortung der Eltern
zusammen mit den Medizinern mit den
Kinderärzten gelegt werden und deswegen
ist es auch nicht in Ordnung nicht
korrekt dass jetzt die AFD versucht das
auszuhebeln und in ihrem Antrag
sozusagen diese Entscheidung wegnimmt
die Entscheidung was passieren soll das
sollte in einem geschützten Raum im
Rahmen Kinderarzt Eltern Kind getroffen
werden und nirgendwo sonst und deshalb
ist
frau Kollegin erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der afd-fraktion
natürlich
vielen Dank ist Ihnen bekannt dass
Eltern bzw einen Elternteil den
Verantwortlichen Elternteil ein Kind
weggenommen wurde weil die Mutter das
nicht wollte dass das Kind geimpft wurde
es wurde vom Jugendamt der Mutter
weggenommen ist in das bekannt weil sie
sagen die Eltern sollen die
Verantwortung übernehmen es ist leider
nicht so es ist leider nicht so also mir
ist so ein Fall nicht bekannt dass
aufgrund dass das Jugendamt
eingeschritten ist weil eine Mutter oder
zu einer mit dem Kind zusammen sozusagen
zu unterschiedlichen Entscheidungen die
kommen mir ist dieser so ein Fall ist
mir nicht bekannt tatsächlich nicht also
ich kenne so einen Fall nicht sondern
ich kenne ganz viele Kinderärzte ganz
viele Familien die das Miteinander
abgewogen haben entschieden haben und es
macht sich auch keine Mutter so ist es
mir lebe ich das in der Praxis kein
Elternteil macht sich das leicht eine
Entscheidung in dem Bereich zu treffen
sondern da wird sich informiert da wird
sich abgesprochen und mir ist dieser
Fall wie sie in schildern nicht bekannt
[Applaus]
die Bitte wäre aber um heute auch noch
mal ins Ausblick ins nächste Jahr zu
bringen wir können uns natürlich davon
auch nicht einschüchtern lassen oder
irgendwie Sorge davor haben uns mit dem
Thema Corona noch mal zur beschäftigen
mein Anliegen wäre nämlich wäre eine
onkette-kommission die wir miteinander
einrichten müssen dafür würde ich sehr
werben denn die Frage was haben wir aus
Corona gelernt welche Konsequenzen hat
es für die Versorgung in ambulanten
Bereich beispielsweise dass man eben
nicht einfach ein Antibiotika
verschreibt sondern vorher testet über
ein Antibiogramm welches Antibiotika ist
sinnvoll oder wie gehen wir eben im
Bereich der Kinder Kitas und so weiter
um was machen wir in den alten
Pflegeheimen das sind alle Dinge da
würde ich mir einen Rahmen wünschen und
würde sehr am Unterstützung werden dass
wir da uns in einer und catkommission
für die Zukunft auch miteinander
austauschen denn wir müssen die Lehren
aus Corona definitiv ziehen und können
nicht zulassen dass dann immer mal
wieder tröpfchenweise eine neue
Erkenntnis kommt sondern ich würde mir
sehr wünschen wir bündeln diese
Erkenntnisse dass wir dann auch gut und
selbstbewusst entscheiden können für die
nächsten Jahre falls wieder so eine
Situation auftreten sollte vielen Dank
die voraussichtlich vorletzte Rednerin
in der laufenden Debatte auf Antrag der
AFD kommt 19 Impfungen und
atemschutzmaskenpflicht betreffen bzw
abschaffen ist jetzt Linda Heitmann von
den bündnisgründen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen der
demokratischen Fraktionen und liebe
afd-fraktion ich habe mir ihren Antrag
angeguckt und durchgelesen und ehrlich
gesagt hatte ich im Zuge dessen ein
Déjà-vu der ungefähr 30 letzten
Sitzungen des Gesundheitsausschusses
regelmäßig zitieren Sie einzelne Studien
aus der medizinischen Forschung sie
picken sich Einzelaspekte herausbringen
ihre eigene Interpretation hinein und
versuchen das Ganze dann zu
skandalisieren der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär hat vorletzte Sitzung es
ziemlich gut auf den Punkt getroffen als
er sagte eine einzelne Studie bringt uns
in der Medizin selten echte Erkenntnisse
man braucht mehrere die man miteinander
in Beziehung setzt und erst dann kommt
man in der Forschung wirklich weiter
aber mehrere Dinge wirklich sinnvoll
miteinander in Beziehung zu setzen das
ist von ihnen offenbar zu viel verlangt
und und was die medizinische Forschung
angeht auch Frau baradari hat es schon
betont es ist einfach nicht unsere
Aufgabe als Politik Nebenwirkungen von
Impfstoffen oder Medikamenten zu
erforschen und es ist auch nicht unsere
Aufgabe als Politik über deren Zulassung
oder Empfehlung zu entscheiden und
darüber dass das nicht unsere Aufgabe
als Politik ist darüber bin ich offen
gestanden auch sehr froh aber
aber es ist unsere Aufgabe als Politik
den Gesundheitszustand unserer
Bevölkerung gut im Auge zu behalten und
entsprechend darüber zu entscheiden
welche erforschten und zugelassenen
Medikamente und Therapien möglicherweise
Sinn machen und wo man vielleicht auch
noch mehr Geld in Forschung und
Entwicklung stecken sollte um wirklich
zu guten Ergebnissen zu kommen und
deshalb haben wir auch Geld hier nochmal
speziell in die Forschung auch für
Therapien gegen longkowid gesteckt im
letzten Haushalt und das finde ich noch
mal einen sehr wichtigen Aspekt in
dieser Debatte denn was wir wirklich
nachgewiesener Weise wissen ist dass die
Impfung das Risiko an long kovi zu
erkranken
nachgewissermaßen senkt aber wir stehen
hier in der Forschung was die Behandlung
dieses erkrankungsbildes und auch die
Diagnostik angeht leider noch am Anfang
und da müssen wir noch viel besser
werden
aber ja es ist ein Problem die Techniker
Krankenkasse hat ihre Zahlen 2020 und
2021 ausgewertet und ein Prozent ihrer
Versicherten waren mit der Diagnose long
kovid ausgefallen in diesem Zeitraum und
zwar im Schnitt für 83 Tage ich finde
das muss uns wirklich zeigen wir müssen
hier mehr forschen wie wir dieser
Krankheit wirksam begegnen und wir
müssen hier die Versorgung wirklich
dringend gut verbessern für die
Betroffenen deshalb hören Sie bitte mit
Ihrem billigen Populismus auf und
arbeiten Sie mit uns gemeinsam
konstruktiv daran Wege zu finden wie wir
die Versorgung und die Forschung in
diesem Bereich von longkowid wirklich
voranbringen um hier sinnvoll etwas zu
bewegen vielen Dank
soweit Linda Heitmann von den
Bündnisgrünen
Gesundheitsausschuss Mitglied und jetzt
wie es aussieht letzter Redner der sich
aus der cdu/csu-fraktion aber der letzte
Redner der gesamten Debatte Erwin rüttel
auch er ist Mitglied im
Gesundheitsausschuss den Antrag der
afd-fraktion halte ich nicht für
zielführend wir haben in einigen reden
sehr deutlich vernommen wie
differenziert die STIKO hier
Empfehlungen gibt und wir sollten froh
und stolz sein dass wir eine unabhängige
STIKO haben die wissenschaftlich basiert
diese Empfehlungen den Eltern gibt
für immung gesunde Kinder ohne
Vorerkrankungen wird keine Impfung
empfohlen weil schwere Verläufe eher
selten sind und schließlich rät die
sticko mit Blick auf den Schutz von
Angehörigen und weiteren Kontaktpersonen
für alle Kinder unter 12 Jahren die
Eltern entscheiden zu lassen ob geimpft
werden soll oder nicht meine Damen und
Herren ich weiß wirklich nicht was es an
diesen Empfehlungen auszusetzen gibt es
wird hier kein Zwang ausgeübt es handelt
sich stets um eine freie Entscheidung
der Eltern beraten durch Kinderärzte und
Ärzte orientiert an der unabhängigen
Entscheidung der STIKO es geht hier um
den Gesundheitsschutz für vulnerable
Gruppen und als positiven Nebeneffekt
werden die Kliniken die derzeit
bekanntlich eh unter Druck sind
entlastet und
das im vorliegenden Antrag Misstrauen
gegenüber Impfungen mitschwingen sollte
kann ich nur feststellen dass Impfschutz
der beste Schutz anerkannte Schutz gegen
Infektionskrankheiten ist den wir haben
impfungen gehören zu den effektivsten
Präventionsmaßnahmen zum Schutz vor
Infektionskrankheiten nicht zuletzt
den zur Verfügung stehenden Impfstoffen
haben wir es zu verdanken dass für heute
in einer ganz anderen Situation sind als
noch vor zwei Jahren als es diesen
Impfstoff nicht gab und wir über das
Impfen den Weg zurück in die Normalität
gefunden haben ein paar Worte noch zum
Tragen von Masken Maßnahmen zum Tragen
von Masken im Gesundheitsbereich sollten
wir diskutieren und im Einzelfall
bewerten ansonsten würde ich mir
wünschen die restlichen Maßnahmen wie
eine maskenpflicht den Bahn oder ÖPNV
abzubauen jedem steht dabei frei und wir
sehen das auch hier im Plenum persönlich
sich für das Tragen einer Maske zu
Entscheidung zu entscheiden die
Erfahrungen anderer Länder zeigen uns
aber auch das mit Masken Verzicht kein
signifikanter Anstieg an Infektionen
verbunden ist genauso so wie Menschen im
Fall einer Erkrankung zu Hause bleiben
sollten auch unabhängig von Corona das
sollte selbstverständlich sein und nicht
gesetzgeberisch geregelt wir müssen als
Gesellschaft wieder den Weg zurück zur
mehr Eigenverantwortung finden und nicht
immer darauf drängen dass jedes Detail
unseres Lebens durch staatliche Vorgaben
geregelt werden soll vielen Dank
ja soweit Erwin rüttel letzte Redner zur
Debatten über 90 Impfungen und
atemschutzmaskenpflicht jetzt wird über
ein Gesetzesantrag und zwei Anträge der
AFD befunden
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere überweisungsvorschläge
das ist nicht der Fall dann sind die
Überweisungen so beschlossen
Zusatzpunkt 14 wir kommen nun zum Antrag
der Fraktion der AFD auf Drucksache 48
93 die Fraktion der AFD wünscht
Abstimmung in der Sache die Fraktionen
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
wünschen Überweisung können Sie noch
kurz zuhören weil wir gerade abstimmen
wünschen Überweisungen und zwar
federführend an den Ausschuss für
Gesundheit und mit beratend an den
Rechtsausschuss sowie an den Verkehrsamt
der Verpflichtung zum Tragen eine
Atemschutzmaske im öffentlichen Personen
Fernverkehr
wer stimmt für die beantragte
Überweisung
das sind alle Fraktionen außer die AFD
wer ist der Gegend damit wird dieser
Antrag der AFD zum Personenfernverkehr
in den zuständigen Ausschuss überwiesen
über den Antrag auf Drucksache 48 93
nicht in der Sache ab